today's topic ben shapiro debunks
systemic racism this is a video that was
submitted to us hundreds of times ok so
there's a video that is going around on
Facebook and on YouTube it's from an axe
TV called systemic racism explain make
some interesting arguments and I thought
it's worthwhile going through them a
little bit so we're gonna play the video
we'll stop it we'll discuss this is
Jamal Jamal is a boy who lives in a poor
neighborhood he has a friend named Kevin
who lives in a wealthy neighborhood all
of Jamal's neighbors are
african-american and all of Kevin's
neighbors are white Kevin and Jamal live
only a few streets away from each other
so how come they're growing up in such
different worlds with such different
opportunities for success the answer has
to do with America's history of systemic
racism to understand it better let's
look at what life was like for Kevin and
Jamal's grandparents in order to
understand what's gonna happen in this
video you have to understand how
systemic racism is being defined
systemic racism is really a morphus term
it could mean many things it could mean
that the institutions of today are
racist in which case everyone would
oppose them or it could mean that all
inequality is explainable by racism
which of course is not sustainable it's
not a good argument the argument that
this video is going to try to make is
that all of history has meaning and that
is true history does have consequences
before today the problem is is we'll see
the video tries to explain all
inequality with reliance on history and
no inequality with response to
exacerbating levels of income inequality
exacerbating levels of single motherhood
personal decision making or any of the
other variables that could come into
creating the gaps we see today decades
after the Civil War many government
agencies started to draw maps dividing
cities into sections that were either
desirable or undesirable for investment
this practice was called redlining and
it usually blocked off entire black
neighborhoods from access to private and
public investment banks and insurance
companies use these maps for decades to
deny black people loans and other
services based purely on race
historically speaking owning home and
getting a college education is the
easiest way for an American family to
build wealth when Jamal's grandparents
wanted to buy a house the banks refused
because they lived in a neighborhood
that was red line so Jamal's
grandparents were not able to buy a home
and because colleges could prevent them
from attending through legal
aggregation their options for higher
education were really scarce so let's
talk about redlining redlining became
illegal in the United States as early as
1968 the Equal Credit Opportunity Act
was followed by the Home Mortgage
Disclosure Act of 1975 which was a
predecessor to the Community
Reinvestment Act both of which were an
attempt to ensure that people who are
living in low-income minority
neighborhoods could actually get loans
and these things were very effective in
1992 researchers at the Federal Reserve
Bank of Boston tried to look at the data
they collected information on some 30
variables related to lending decisions
they found that virtually all of the
difference between minority and
non-minority denial rates was explained
by those variables
okay here's think if you actually read
this study it says this is from what he
posted these factors do not wholly
eliminate the disparity and since the
adjusted ratio implies that even after
controlling for financial employment
neighborhood characteristics black and
historic more urgent applications in the
Boston metropolitan area are roughly 60%
more likely to be turned down than
whites
this discrepancy means that minority
applicants with the same economic and
property characteristics as white
applicants would experience a denial
rate of 17% rather than the actual white
denial rate of 11 thus in the end and
that's what he posted that's what he
posted so even the study that he posted
admits that there's still a discrepancy
that exists when you control for all
those factors a reanalysis of that
information found that black owned bags
were actually lending to white owned
businesses at higher rates than they
were lending to black owned businesses
furthermore if it seemed that banks were
discriminating against black borrowers
on the basis of they needed to have
higher credit qualifications what you
would see is lower default rates from
black clients of banks from people who
are borrowing money from banks and black
community there are zero studies that
show any of this so the bottom line is
this redlining
was in evil and awful policy it was
maybe legal in the 1960s by the 1980s it
the banks were not lending at
disproportionate rates in fact if you
look at among different communities as
Thomas ol has pointed out
asian-americans get loans more easily
than white Americans that does not mean
the banks are being racist toward white
Americans on behalf of Asian Americans
okay so first thing I want to give I'm
gonna give them credit
for this one point he at least
acknowledges red linings history and the
fact that it discriminate against
minorities there's two things he doesn't
account for one it's not because a
policy has been made illegal that the
practice has stopped as recent as 2015
the Justice Department has actually come
down on banks for still redlining
against African Latino community members
meaning they still discriminated on the
basis of race when he claims to giving
out loan and so you guys can look this
up the settlements have already been put
in place the idea that redlining has
stopped because a law has been enacted
to me seems weird because the reality is
they're still charging people for that
exact same crime so if you acknowledge
that redlining is a form of systemic
racism that has existed in the past and
has been outlawed yet you recognize that
it is systemic racism if it's still
being practiced has that systemic racism
really gone that's my question
then himself acknowledge that that was a
form of systemic reason that is real
that is problematic so just because it's
outlawed it doesn't change the fact that
it's still happening so if that fund
that he claimed was evil it's still
happening today is systemic racism
really god that's the question I posed
to you well of course not if it's like
anything even slavery slavery was
abolished abolished there was no slave
but there are still slaves right now
it's almost 13 I'm talking about the
u.s. yes basically yes you are not to be
on as a slave yes you're imprisoned yes
right but yeah I just don't like the
idea that his argument is essentially
because it's been outlawed that ain't
necessary there's not happening and what
we actually know from public records is
that that it's not the case he is
correct about affirmative action the one
thing I would also add though is that a
lot of people are getting into
universities through nepotism meaning
because their parents who went to those
universities are part of the Alumni in
who are boosters they get their kids to
go through while still having bad GPAs
and all this stuff their kids get in so
that economic advantage that they have
from being from wealth is passed down to
their kids now is that inherently just
along racial lines no it's also along
economic lines and it's important that
when we look at this issue we don't look
at it as a strictly race thing because
the reality is money
a huge factor your social class plays a
huge factor in this but it's also
important to note as men will do later
that because black people have been so
de disadvantaged economically speaking
and and discriminated against from that
point of view it stands to reason that
there's going to be some overlap between
race and income unfortunately the story
doesn't end there
a big part of systemic racism is
implicit bias these are prejudices in
society that people are not aware that
they have one of the big problems with
implicit bias it is very very difficult
to quantify identify and studies that
supposedly determine that your implicit
bias results in real world action are
deeply flawed implicit bias assessment
tests for example are so significantly
flawed they're virtually unusable let's
go back to Kevin and Jamal
against all odds Jamal manages to be the
only student from his high school to get
accepted into a great university the
same one that Kevin and his high school
friends are attending but after Kevin
and Jamal both graduate Jamal notices
that his resume isn't drawing as much
interest as Kevin's even though they
graduated from the same program with the
exact same GPA
unfortunately for Jamal studies show
that resumes with white sounding names
at twice as many callbacks as identical
resumes with black sounding names the
research is actually a lot more
interesting than what is being portrayed
in this video there are several studies
here there is one famous study that was
done that suggested that first name
differentiation was indeed being used by
employer so if your name was Lakeisha
for example this is the name that is
actually used in the study Lakeisha
versus Greg that you are less likely to
get a call back there's another study
that showed a historically black last
name like Washington or Jefferson
provided no actual differentiation from
historically white names a Greenberg for
example hold up Washington and Jefferson
alright when I hear that name most
people hear that name they don't think
black person is because of the first
thing that you're gonna think black mean
if you think your last name is Jefferson
that's one thing if your name is grey
Jefferson white if you say
Lakeisha Jefferson but even if it's Ben
Jefferson that's not a you
because he's saying he's making an
argument that Jefferson and Washington
are historically black nation yes
I'll beat honest with you when people
hear Jefferson or Washington they think
were the founding fathers they don't
think of football players straight that
fast so that to me seems like an odd
point to make to be like they don't
discriminate against Washington's and
Jefferson's because they don't sound
black it's not because you took that you
took danzo's last name and the
Jeffersons show that we gonna yeah
they're black if you don't get that yo
you know what Smith is a black man look
whatever Will Smith get off take it no
no no daddy
Lakeisha is a different I don't know too
many white girls of the name latisha do
you I don't miss I know plenty of white
dudes with Washington Jefferson Smith
come on Courtney so if your name was
Steve Greenberg versus Steve Jefferson
you're just as likely get a call back as
Steve Jefferson and that's what I'm
saying he's being this engine with he's
not being real good well I know at the
very least he's actually quoting the
study which I'm grateful for
yes please everything in Washington to
be fair like me maybe he doesn't know
that many black people so he doesn't
know that it doesn't matter you're able
to search for research for four you know
this research and then four names you're
not able to look it up nah look it up
buddy look it up do you know all the
what traditional names look like for
everything no but I'm just saying look
it up be able to go up with all these
I'm not giving with benefit in doubt I'm
gonna give him the benefit you don't
have to I believe them the benefit of
the doubt be come on you may not know I
understand some people are not that
culture already know all of this thing
no we didn't regret this study and the
daddy used those names as black examples
he'll be too whack hot hated it let's go
what that suggests and this was
confirmed by subsequent studies is that
the actual issue here is a question of
class discrimination not an issue of
race discrimination in other words the
reason that people are discriminating
against Lakeisha as opposed to against
Steve Johnson or Steve Washington is the
people are actually using the first name
as it stands in for social class what
are you trying to say door and Steve is
rich so you're gonna hire the Keisha
because she's poor you've literally said
that income mobility is the best thing
and anything if you have a poor sounding
name you're not gonna get hired because
that sounded weird what
that's a weird argument to make Jamal
I'd hire you but it sounds like you're
gonna get drafted to the NBA anytime
soon so can't afford to have a part of
my works like come on would you're
making assumptions of people based off
their cultural background you're just
saying if you say you belong to the
black community therefore you're
probably poor I don't know why you
wouldn't want to hire a poor person if
they're just as qualified as the white
counterpart that sounds strange to me
but anyways I'm trying to see from
history story no sir yeah ammaji just be
honest with it it's a whack argument
they're figuring that if you were named
Lakeisha it's because you probably came
from a more impoverished background now
this is not restricted to the black
community this happens in the Jewish
community as well if you get an
applicant and the applicants name is Ben
you might treat that applicant different
than if that person's name is Benny I
mean you might treat them Anathem
different than you treat a Mike and that
is because you are trying to read into
the person your perceptions of culture
or perceptions of class not really
perceptions of race but that sounds a
lot like racism I don't know to y'all
but if I hear a name me black
he probably commits crime listen if you
if you listen to a name and then you
infer some kind of criminality some kind
of wealth problem some kind of mental
aptitudes lacking that sounds a lot like
racism okay maybe it's a cultural thing
are you trying to say I'm not racist I'm
you xenophobic like what are we arguing
here you really trying to hire Jamal I
don't know there's a Jamal that stole my
credit card get a day that's really
really important when you look at these
particular studies and suggest that
racial discrimination rather than class
distinctions are at the basis of
whatever hiring discrimination is
happening here it makes me think of when
everybody said whatever the cop said
it's not racial profiling its entire
prior profiling come on that's that's
what it sounds like yeah
this is one of the problem is right it's
like when you outline something in a red
lining now they're not discriminating on
you based off of your race explicitly
now they're being like yeah we just feel
like you know based off your heritage
it's the same thing it's just got a
different name
Oh based on my heritage you mean my hair
class discrimination come on be that's a
bad argument
Kevin's grandparents on the other hand
at a low-interest loan to buy their
first house and get accepted into a
handful of top universities which
traditionally only accepted white
students this opened up a wealth of
opportunities that they were able to
pass on to their kids and grandkids
the basic assumption of this video is
that if your grandparents are rich in
the United States this means that you
are rich in the United States and if
your grandparents are poor in the United
States that means that you are poor in
the United States this is factually
untrue the reality is that income
changes over time that there are an
enormous number of people in the United
States by percentage who are able to
rise from portes middle class and their
children from middle class to wealthy
the biggest problem that we have in the
United States right now is not a
historic wealth gap the biggest problem
we have is an income gap in the United
States furthermore the basic idea that
most wealth in the United States is
inherited and the millionaires are
really only millionaires because their
parents were millionaires that really
isn't true either the vast majority of
millionaires and billionaires are people
whose parents were not millionaires and
billionaires chris hogan who's a black
financial expert he did a survey of
10,000 people and what he found was that
of those 10,000 people 74% of
millennials believed millionaires
inherited their money 52% of baby
boomers did but only 21% of millionaires
received any inheritance at all just 16%
inherited more than $100,000 only 3%
received an inheritance at or above 1
million dollars in reality the best path
toward wealth in this country is income
mobility not inherited wealth ok so he's
not wrong about that all right he's
actually right about what he says that
being said I think he dismisses the
advantages of being born to her wealthy
family a little bit too much because you
can't just look at as oh I didn't get
anything from my parents cuz I didn't
get any Herenton snow I got a lot of
things you got you benefit from being in
a place of high property values that
means you went to a better education
right your parents who are wealthy
probably have more connections than poor
families which meant it's much easier
for you to land a job land a good school
all of your food
right you know like to think that you
know there's much much upward mobility
for a child in Flint drinking led water
as someone who's born to a wealthy
family to me is ridiculous obviously
what kind of social class you're born
into it plays a huge factor and the idea
that upward mobility is going to be just
as accessible to poor kids as it will be
the rich kids to me seems a little
strange that being said he is he is
right that ideally the solution to this
problem is upward mobility but what we
see is that most poor people stay poor
and most middle-class people stay
middle-class problem with point is that
it really takes account for just one
side of the story you understand yeah I
understand your example that we just
have here I understand that you know
they don't inherit anything but it's
just you you really take in Phasis of
inheriting of wealth but there's more
than that you don't taking
accountability anything else that's what
I have a problem with but whatever we'll
go this opened up a wealth of
opportunities that they were able to
pass on to their kids and grandkids even
as late as the 1980s an investigation
into the Atlanta real-estate market
showed that banks were more willing to
lend to low-income white families than
to middle or upper income
african-american families as the result
today for every hundred dollars of
wealth held by a white family black
families have five dollars and four
cents it 2017 study confirms that
redlining is still affecting home values
and major cities like Chicago today this
explains how Kevin and Jamal inherited
vastly different circumstances as it
turns out there were some complicating
factors that don't get cited in this
video through guard to the state of the
Federal Reserve Board economists tried
to explain that this data did not take
account of differences that were not
income based things like liabilities
employment history credit record and
other relevant variables that should
have been considered it should not be
particularly surprising that
discrimination in the past has impact on
the actual income of people who are
living in the areas that were denied
loans that shouldn't be a major surprise
but that is not the only disparity
obviously that New York Times piece they
are citing says quote they estimate the
map's account for 15 to 30 percent of
the overall gaps in segregation and home
ownership
so then you're making the case for
systemic raising the idea that systemic
racism is the only reason why people are
being held back is not one that most
logical people are going to make they're
saying it is a contributing factor
right of course personal decisions and
you know family surroundings all these
other things are going to play impact
but you've just literally stated that it
does have an impact in the homeownership
of people there today so when people say
you're debunking systemic racism it
seems odd to me one right here you're
acknowledging that it does have an
impact on today's real estate
opportunities for minority communities
so he tosses out the window because it's
really just one-sided well I don't know
if he's tossed it because he's
acknowledging it so he's not tossing it
up he's debunks it you came out calling
debunking you cannot make a video
talking about
I'm debunking it when you acknowledge it
which after that if you if you clearly
said she'd be bunking it it means that
she's saying that you're tossing it out
the window because you're not taking
this in accountability maybe it's just a
title maybe is just a title
maybe maybe but it just seems odd to me
that you're saying you're going to
debunk it and then at the same time you
were saying no it really does have an
impact today then that's the case that
most people are making I will
acknowledge this what he's when he
quotes the studies he doesn't do so in a
disingenuous manner which I appreciate
but he takes only one well he's not
because he's mentioning both sides right
now
that's literally CIS but the first time
that he does that's the first time in
the whole video that he did oh yeah now
923 and that's the first time that he
thought oh gee the both sides out of
everything that you said I don't know
okay that they find between the highest
risk area and the second highest risk
areas those were the ones that are being
classified the truth is that when it
comes to redlining you have to look at
the gradations as well there was always
going to be a difference in the
availability of loans to people who are
living in the highest risk areas as
opposed to the people who are in the
very lowest risk areas another factor is
that if history does make a difference
then if you are denied loans in a
particular area and if there's less
money in those areas and as crime goes
up and as property taxes kick in there's
not enough money to take in as schools
get worse obviously that's going to
continue to have effect in that
particular area that doesn't mean the
same people are living in that area who
always lived in that area or the people
who grew up in that area in 1960
necessarily have to live in that area or
that their grandkids have to live in
area in 2020 here's a thing
statistically speaking we know that most
poor people do not move right like for
higher income people it's much more
accessible to move because you have more
financial flexibility to go somewhere
else for poor people you guys can look
this up yourselves they don't move as
much so he's saying essentially if you
live in an area and you were shafted you
know generally generationally speaking
by redlining and bad loan practices move
what most poor people don't have that up
opportunities awful thing when you're
living paycheck to paycheck okay and
you're just trying to make rent and you
don't know you're gonna have a job in
the next city you can't just up and move
you're saying that he's not being
disingenuous but I feel like he is in a
bit in a way because he's disregarding a
bunch of things because Jamal school
district is mostly funded by property
taxes his school is not very well funded
his classrooms are overcrowded his
teachers are underpaid and he doesn't
have access to high quality tutors or
extracurricular activities
Kevon school district is also funded by
property taxes so high school is very
well funded his classrooms are never
crowded his teachers are very well-paid
and he has access to high quality tutors
and lots of extracurricular activities
so let's talk for a second about school
policy the reality is that if you wanted
Jamal to be able to go to Kevin's school
what you want is something called school
vouchers you want people to be able to
move away from their school districts
one of the chief reasons that Jamal is
confined to his local public school is
because of Democratic policy that has
decided that you must go to school in
the district where you live and this is
also why a lot of people have left
lower-income areas and moved out to
higher income areas specifically for
better public school so if you want
Jamal to have the same educational
opportunities as Kevin perhaps you
should have school vouchers for private
schools or perhaps you should have
charter schools which is what Mayor Bill
DeBlasio in New York is fighting against
or perhaps you should break the teachers
unions which are costing a fortune
particularly on a disproportionate level
in areas where they're not spending
enough taxpayer dollars so I'm all for
improving Jamal schools I'm also offered
Jamal having all the same educational
opportunities as Kevin the problem is
most Democrats are not okay I don't
entirely disagree at this point but it
seems kind of odd to say you can move or
you can say sometimes schools are not
necessarily well placed it let's say if
I'm living in an area and always close
by school that we have access to is this
one well just to say to someone take a
voucher and go to a different school
well that's not a tenable situation for
all those kids that go to that school
the bad school meaning because then if
all those kids leave that bad school to
go to a better school then those other
schools become overcrowded and the other
thing to consider is like not everyone
can just move for school purposes like
if you were poor as a point if you're
poor you don't you're not able to move
it's very rare for poor people they move
why because cost of living is pretty
high in most places in North America so
to move from where you're at which you
know you've kind of established some
kind of system to move somewhere else
try to find a new job
trying to find a location that's close
to that school it's very difficult so
this that's wondering about because he
just said well if you want to have a
better school you just have to move and
I'm like well that's the problem is that
if you said that the area where you
where you live at is financing with the
school taxes and stuff like that it's
financing the schools then you just
moving increases your cost of living
which you can't necessarily afford so
I'm like yo that point is weird ya know
and if all those kids move then the
other schools that then become
overcrowded so it's not a tenable
situation ideally you'd want to make
those schools much better so that
they're up to the standard of the other
schools as far as starting charter
schools yes that's always a good idea
but it's also expensive to do it's not
it's not as instantaneously on what
territory I'm the one that can afford it
well charter schools are a little bit
different than but yeah I don't entirely
disagree with him but I'd also think
it's solution is implicit bias is one of
the reasons why the black unemployment
rate is twice the rate of white
unemployment
well this tends to neglect one key
factor what did you major in what did
you study it turns out that people who
major in education are gonna do as well
as people who major in engineering
according to research from the Center on
education and the workforce at
Georgetown University this is a quote
from PBS african-american college
students are more likely to pursue
majors that lead to low-paying jobs
setting up many for future debt and
underemployment over time these
occupational choices contribute to the
wealth and opportunity gap between
whites and blacks that spans at
generations Anthony karneval who's the
director of the program says basically
african-americans have been going to the
right church but sitting in the wrong
pew in a way they are using education to
climb the social and economic ladder but
they're being steered toward majors that
will make them low earners so in other
words there are several confounding
factors that are not being taken into
account in this
one what college did you go to - what
did you major in and three what kind of
job did you get afterward so this is I
think the trend I'm seeing the guy in
the original video the one that Ben's
reacting to is making the assessment
that all inequalities due to racial
discrimination and and and and systemic
racism and then Ben is making the
argument that it's a whole bunch of
other stuff therefore you're wrong why
can't it be both why can't it be a
matter of personal choices the schools
you choose to go to and because my name
is Jamal you think I'm poor therefore
you're not gonna hire me it could be
both of those things and if you combine
them personal choice matters yes right
the choices that you make for school all
that matters what where you send your
kids look honey environments of manners
and systemic racism which you've
acknowledged in this video also matters
it can be both they're not arguing the
same thing he's talking about system
racism and you know one is talking about
some other thing disregarding system
making racism even though he said that
exist if not because of that this time
they're not even he's responding with
things that have nothing to do with what
he's talking about well he's trying to
say you're looking at the wrong stuff
yeah actually this stuff so that's his
response yes response is like but it's
both I knew we are acknowledging yeah
you can see evidence of systemic racism
in every area of life the disparities
and family wealth incarceration rates
political representation and education
are all examples of systemic racism now
we reach the crux of the matter the
basic idea here is that any inequality
can be chalked up to systemic racism we
are now ghost-hunting notice they've
said nothing in this video about
incarceration nothing about
incarceration the simple assumption is
that if more black people
percentage-wise are arrested than white
people that must be due to systemic
racism and not due to the number of
crimes being committed by individuals
who make a decision to commit a crime
both those things can be true both of
them is the trend in this yes
personal choices bad personal choices
resulting you going to jail also
partially systemic racism is a factor
you know like okay now he's gonna make
this certain that there's a whole bunch
of black people who work in government
in these offices great what are the
percentages what are the percentages
it's not because Barack Obama can be
present the United States the systemic
racism doesn't exist
that's not argument that you need to
make it can be both those things people
can make the right personal choices and
good place in life but we saw something
knowledge that sometimes systemic racism
came shafts when it comes to
representation the truth is there are
many many black Americans in Congress
we've had a black presidents of the
United States people choosing to run in
people choosing to vote that is an
aspect of American freedom and when it
comes to education there are plenty of
affirmative action programs that exist
at virtually every major university in
fact their entire university systems
like the University of California that
have gotten rid of the SAT and the a CT
as admissions criteria specifically
because they weren't allowing enough
minority students to attend so to
attribute all inequality to systemic
racism is simply to say that everything
you don't like must be due to systemic
racism unfortunately the biggest
challenge of systemic racism is that
there's no single person or entity
responsible for it which makes it very
hard to solve what he just said about
there's no one person you can ascribe it
to there's no face of it and if I can
point to note that like when you talk
about systemic racism you don't have to
look at white people like you're guilty
of this sometimes people could be
complicit in the system and not even
realize it
for example not saying this is my
opinion but if I looked at police
officers and I went looking at the
police system and I said hey the laws of
they're enacting so for example if they
were violating your Second Amendment
rights
okay they were taking away your guns
against your rights okay the police
officers were told to do it and they did
it but those police officers may not be
evil but they are upholding a system
that is violating your rights meaning
they may not be intentionally doing
anything they may not have bad
intentions but because they are the arm
of that system and engaging in it
they're the bad ones do you understand
what I'm saying these people are not
waking up in the morning say oh I'm
gonna infringe their rights right
everything I'm gonna do that under
rights no there are most of them most of
the time or executing orders it's not
it's not them saying it's what the order
is right that man I got pushed right and
the old man I got pushed in that hole
got cracked it was an order yeah it was
in order that was that was asked to be
done do you understand so I understand
after that why that's 57 people this
they decided to resign from that task
force not from the police but from that
four because at the end of the day they
were not okay you asked me to do a job
but you're not gonna back
you up in the end right I don't want to
be me but I'm just trying to do my job
when I'm framed in the same token
soldiers who can be sent to an unjust
war can be good people but because
they're a part of a system that's making
them do something that's unjust and to
be clear most people agree that the war
in Afghanistan in Iraq was wrong now not
back then but now it doesn't mean that
it reflects on their character in that
same token just because systemic racism
exists it doesn't mean that white people
everywhere are guilty of this problem do
you understand so when we have this
discussion don't feel defensive don't
feel like oh and we're not saying that
white people can't suffer or why people
can't be poor or why people can receive
very little to no handouts that's not
what we're saying
we're saying there is a system that
purposefully discriminates against black
on the basis of their skin as Ben has
admitted which is redlining
and there's other forms of it but we're
gonna just stick to what he mentioned so
what can you do the first thing you can
do is work towards becoming more aware
of your own implicit biases we should
always as decent people be re-examining
our own biases in trying to wipe out bad
thoughts who may be having about other
people but the idea that something is
vague as you had a bad thought about a
group is now responsible for the income
inequality between black and white is
sort of an absurd contention in the
absence of any available evidence what
are some prejudices that you might hold
that you're not aware of second let's
acknowledge that the consequences of
slavery and Jim Crow laws are still
affecting access to opportunity today it
is certainly plausible that slavery and
Jim Crow have affected how people's
paths have gone in life and the
circumstances of their birth but the
question is how much if we are going to
change policy and if we are going to
effectuate change
shouldn't we be focused more on what are
the bad policies today that specifically
are keeping people down and what
behaviors can we change today to make
our opportunities better rather than
focusing in on slavery or Jim Crow the
fact is that even if you buy into the
entire narrative of systemic racism
promoted by this video it changes
nothing and the video is even
acknowledging as much I disagree on this
because a lot of people don't
acknowledge this reality because they
don't acknowledge this reality they
don't want to acknowledge a lot of the
changes that people want to implement in
order to fix these we outlawed redlining
great it's still happening today how do
we fix that but if you don't acknowledge
the fact that redlining ever existed or
those ever originally buys which by all
accounts all historical facts it was
then we can't have a discussion on how
to fix it today
we'll have to come to a conclusion in an
acceptance of the facts of this history
in order for us to move forward
we had truth and conciliation here in
regards to Native Americans and what the
Canadian government did to them still a
long way to go but the at least came to
the point where they acknowledged it and
now we can do some moving forward in
order to fix that am I wrong without
even acknowledging you're not so that's
why I disagree with him on but anyways
I'll keep going as a result we should
support systemic changes that create
more equal opportunities for everyone
increasing public school funding and
making it independent from property
taxes would be a great start so that
poor and wealthy districts can receive
equal access to resources the suggestion
that simply pouring money into public
schools is somehow going to be the
solution has been bolide by nearly every
independent study ever done of public
education obviously we should be
spending more on sitting on schools
where not enough spending is going on
where there aren't school books or there
aren't enough desks but the real problem
that's existing in educational
performance has very little to do with
income and a lot more to do with the
access to educational opportunity
provided in in homes if you have a
single family home it is very difficult
for mom to be able to help with homework
if you don't allow kids to go to better
schools outside their neighborhood
rather than simply pouring money into
failed neighborhood schools then you're
not really granting opportunity he's
right about that he's right about that I
actually looked up the studies just to
double-check most of them say if you
just throw money out of school they
don't have the system in place to be
able to use it appropriately but there's
no doubt that underfunded schools I
can't even give kids basic tech books
yeah an adequate teachers and
after-school curricular schools know
clean drinking water it's not even that
it's just like yeah I got 30 kids and I
got 13 English books and I got 15 math
book like what the hell are you talking
about yeah what are you even talking
about lady you have 13 math books for
your class of 30 yeah and 50 it's a
problem and you know what the issue with
it is like the u.s. in particular
doesn't rank really highly in terms of
their education levels at those levels
systemic problems require systemic
solutions luckily we're all part of the
system which means that we all have a
role to play
making it better peace it's easy enough
to say that we all have a role in making
the system better but when you suggest
very few practical solutions other than
rote democratic policies that have been
failed nearly every time they've tried
it makes it difficult to believe this
isn't just a political ploy rather than
an argument in favor of bettering
individual human lives to deny the
effective history would be idiotic
history obviously has consequences and
to deny that racism exists would be
similarly idiotic but to attribute every
problem in American life to racism or
inequity is to be foolish and
counterproductive and not to make the
world a better place I agree in my last
point you can't attribute everything to
racism all right some of it is a matter
of class some of it is a matter of
income even when it comes to these
protests and rights I'm like you guys
are so focused on this police we have to
acknowledge the fact that income
inequality is also a big problem that we
have in North America and Western
civilization in general the biggest
indicator and the biggest correlating
point you can find for revolts and
rights in most countries throughout
history has been income inequality the
poor people get the more upset they get
with the the upper class and then as a
result that anger builds up builds up
until there's a boiling point right so I
agree with him on that point but I just
find it weird that you title it
debunking systemic racism while
simultaneously acknowledging the fact
that racism does exist and acknowledging
different forms of systemic racism so to
me it's just a title that really
bothered me otherwise I didn't mind the
video too much except for one or two
points that's what I have to say about
it what do you think I'll call it
debunking okay but that's clickbait and
there's you post pictures and things
that you talking about but you don't
really read the whole thing it's really
one-sided that's what I that's what I
found so I'm like yeah whatever it's
just Ben Shapiro beings man Shapiro so I
was like thing is that Ben Shapiro has a
big ability to sound smarter and he
really is you smart he goes with that he
goes with uh with studies when it
benefits whatever he's saying but then
if I dismiss some other points whenever
it doesn't or it's not worth going
because it's gonna go against whatever
he's saying so I'm like
that's why I'm not really a fan of Ben I
could listen to them because sometimes
they're gonna bring another incentive
he's gonna bring another another point
to what I'm what I'm thinking and what
I'm here but it's like it's sometimes
it's very one-sided and you're not
trying to you're not you're purposely
not trying to look at the whole picture
or what it's trying to be said and
that's what I thought about this video
cool
we want to hear your thoughts what are
you guys think in the comments below do
you agree or disagree with our specimen
we want to hear your thoughts
[Music]
you